um my name is vladislav mladna for just
vladi if you have some questions to me
and this is fabian and we are allowed
today to talk about how to break pdf
security or more special
about how to break the cryptography
operations
in pdf files we are a large team from
university on bohom minster and hackman
gamberha so um
as i mentioned we will talk about
cryptography in pdf files
does it work
all right okay
let's try that again okay perfect this
talk will
consist of two parts the first part is
about digitally signed
pdf files and how can we recognize such
files
if we open them we see the
information regarding the that the file
was signed and all verification
procedures were valid and more
information
regarding the signature validation panel
and information about
who signed this file this is the first
part of the talk and
i will present this topic
and the second part is regarding pdf
encrypted files and how can we recognize
such files if we you try to open such
files the first thing you see is the
password prompt
and after entering the correct password
the file is decrypted
and you can read the content within this
file
if you open it with adobe additional
information regarding
if this file is secured or not is
displayed further and this is the second
part of our talk and fabian we will talk
how can we break the pdf encryption
so before we start with the
attacks on signatures or encryption we
first need some basics and after six
slides
you will be experts regarding pdf files
and you will understand everything about
it
but um maybe it's a little bit boring so
be patient
there are only six slides so the first
is quite easy
pdf files are um the first specification
was in 1993
and almost at the beginning uh pdf
cryptography operations like signatures
and
encryption was already there the last
version
is pdf 2.0 and it was released in 2017
and according to adobe 1.6 billion files
um are on the web and perhaps more
exchange
beyond the web so basically
pdf files are everywhere and that's the
reason why
we considered this topic and tried to
find or to analyze the security of the
features
if we have some very simple file and we
open it with adobe reader
the first thing we see is of course the
content
hello world in this case and
additional information regarding the
focus page
and how many pages this document has
but what would happen if we don't use a
pdf viewer
and you just use some
text editor we used the notepad plus
plus to open
and um later manipulate the files so i
will zoom this thing
this file and the first thing
we see is that we can read it
perhaps it's quite um quite funny
and um but we can still extract some
information
from of this file for example some
information regarding the pages and
here you can see the information that
one page the the pdf file consists of
one page but more interesting
is that we can see the content of the
file itself
so the lessons we learned is that we can
use a simple text editor
to view and edit pdf files
and for our attacks we use only
this text editor so
let's go to the details how pdf files
are structured
and how they are processed
pdf files consists of four parts header
body and body is the most important part
of the pdf files um
this the body contains the entire
information presented to the user
and two other sections extra section and
trailer
very important thing about processing
pdf files is
that their process not from the top to
the bottom
but from the bottom to the top so the
first thing
is the pdf viewer analyzes or processes
is the trailer so let's start um doing
that
what information is starting this
trailer basically there are two
very important informations on the first
side
this is the information what is the root
element of this pdf so
which is the first object which will be
processed
and the second important information is
where
the xref section starts it's a just a
byte offset pointing to the position of
this extra sections within the pdf file
so this pointer as mentioned before
points to the xref section but what is
the extra section about
the extra section is a catalog pointing
or
holding the information where the
objects defined in the body are
contained or the byte positions of
this object so how can we
read this weird x-ray section the first
thing
the first information we extract is that
the first
object which is defined here is
the object with the id 0 and we have
five further elements or objects which
are defined
so the first object is
here the first entry is the byte
position within the file
the second is its generation number and
the last character points
if this object is used or not used
so reading it reading this x-ray section
we extract the information that the
object with the
d0 is the posit at the byte position
zero and it's not in use so the first
the object with the id one is at the
position
nine and so on and so forth so for the
object
with a d4 and the object
number comes from counting it zero
one two three and four so the object
with the d4
um can be fined at the position at
offset and is in use
in other words the pdf viewer knows
where
each object will be fined and can
properly displace it and process it
now we come to the most important part
the body and i mentioned it
that in the body the entire content
which is presented to the user
is contained so let's see object 4
0 is this one
and as you can see it contains the world
hello world
the other objects are referenced too so
each pointer points exactly to the
starting position of each of the objects
and how can we read this object you see
we have
object starting with the id number with
then the generation number and the word
opt
so you can now um you now know
where the object is starts and when it
ends
now how can we process this body
as i mentioned before in the trailer
there was a reference
regarding the root element and this
element
was with the id one and generation
number zero so
we now we start reading the document
here
and we have a catalog and a reference
to some pages pages is just a
description of all the pages contained
within the file
and what can we see here is that
we have this number count one so we have
only one page
and a reference to the page object which
contains
the entire information description of
the page
if we have multiple pages then we will
have here multiple elements
then we have one page and
here we have the contents which is a
reference
to the string we already saw
perfect if you understand this then you
know everything or almost everything
about pdf files
now you can just use your editor and
open such files and analyze them
then we need one feature
i forgot the last part the most simple
simple one the header it's just one line
stating which
version is used for example in our case
1.4 for the last version of adobe here
will be stated 2.0 now
we need this one feature called
incremental update
and i call this feature do you know this
features highlighting something in the
pdf file
or putting some sticky notes technically
it's called incremental update i just
call it reviewing master and bachelor
thesis of my students
because this is exactly the procedure i
follow
i just read the text and highlight
something and store
the information i put at it
technically by putting
such a sticky note this
additional information is appended
after the end of the file so we have a
body
update which contains exactly the
information only
of the additionally of the new
objects and of course new x-ray section
and
of a new trailer pointing to this
new object okay
we are done how can
considering incremental update um
we sell that it is used to put
for for mainly for sticky notes or
highlighting
but we observed something which is very
important
because in incremental update we can um
redefine existing objects for example we
can define
redefine the object with the d4
and put new content so we replace in
this manner the world
hello world with uh with another
sentence
and of course the x-ray section and the
trailer
point to these new objects so this is
very important so we
we are not with incremental update we
are not stick to only um adding some
highlighting or notes we can redefine
already existing content
and perhaps we need this for the attacks
we will present
so let's talk about pdf signatures
first we need a difference
between electronic signature and digital
signature
electronic signature from a technical
point of view
is just an image i just um
routed it on my pc and put it into the
file
there is no cryptographic protection it
could be me lying on the beach doing
something
from cryptographic point of view is the
same it does not provide any security
any cryptographic security
what we will talk here is about
digitally signed
files so if you open such files um you
have
the additional information regarding um
the validation about
the signatures and who signed this pdf
file
so as i mentioned before this talk will
concentrate
only on this digitally signed pdf files
how what kind of process is behind
digitally signing
pdf files imagine we have this abstract
overview of a pdf document we have the
header body extra section and trailer
and
we want to sign it what happens is
that we take this pdf file and via
incremental update we put additional
information
regarding the there is a new catalog
and more important a new signature
object containing the signature value
and information about
who signed this pdf file and of course
there is a xref section and trailer
and relevant for you the entire file is
now protected by the pdf
signature so manipulations within this
area
should not be possible right
yeah let's talk about this how
why it's not possible and how can we
break it
first we need attack a scenario what we
want to achieve
as an attacker we assumed in our
research that the attacker possess
this signed pdf file this could be an
old contract
receipt or um in our case
a bill from amazon and if we
open this file the signature is valid so
everything is green no warning
are thrown and everything is fine
what we try to do is to take this file
manipulate it somehow
and then send it to the victim
and now the victim expects
to receive a digitally signed pdf file
so just
tripping the digital signature is a very
trivial scenario and we did not consider
it because it's trivial we considered
that the victim expects
to see that there is a signature and it
is valid so no warning
are thrown and the entire left side
is exactly the same from the novel
normal behavior
but on the other side
the content was exchanged so we um we
manipulated the receipt and exchanged it
with another content
the question is now how can we do it on
a technical level and
we came up with three attacks um
incremental saving attacks signature
wrapping and universal signature forgery
and i will now introduce the techniques
and how these attacks are working
the first attack is the incremental
saving attack so i mentioned
before that via incremental saving core
by incremental updates
we can add and remove
and even redefine
already existing objects and the
signature
still stays valid why is this happening
consider now again our case
we have some header body xrf table and
trailer and
the file is now signed and the signature
protects
only designed area so what would happen
if i put a sticky note
or some highlighting an incremental
update happens
if i open this file usually this happens
we have the information that this
signature is valid
when it was signed and so on and so
forth
so our first idea was to just
put new body updates redefine already
existing content
and with the xraf table and trailer
we point to the new content this is
quite
trivial because it's a legitimate
feature in pdf files
so we didn't expect to be quite
successful and we were not
so successful um but the first idea we
applied this attack we opened it and we
got
this message so it's kind of
a weird message because
uh an experienced user
sees valid but the document has been
updated and you should know
what does this exactly mean but we did
not consider this attack as a successful
because
um there's there the warning is not
the same or the status of the signature
validation is not the same
so what we did is to evaluate this
first against this trivial case against
all that all the viewers we have and
libreoffice for example was vulnerable
against this trivial attack on
this was the only viewer which was
vulnerable against
this trivial variation but then we asked
ourselves okay the other viewers are
quite secure but
how do they detect this incremental
updates
and from developer point of view the
laziest thing we can do is just to check
if
another extra tailor a table and trailer
were added after the signature was
applied
so we just put our body updates but
just deleted the other two parts
this is not a standard compliant pdf
file it's
broken but our hope was that the pdf
viewer
fix this kind of stuff for us and
are that these viewers are error
tolerant
and we were quite successful because the
verification
logic just checked is there an extra
table and trailer after the signature
was applied
no okay everything is fine the signature
is valid no warning was thrown
but then the application logic so that
incremental updates were applied and
fixed this for us and processed
this body updates and no warning was
thrown
some of the viewers required to have a
trailer
i don't know why it was a black black
box testing so we just removed the x-ray
table but the trail was there
and we were able to broke further pdf
viewers
the most complex variation of the attack
was the following
we had the pdf viewers checked if
every incremental update contains
a signature object
but they did not check if this signature
is covered by the incremental update so
we just
copy pasted the signature which was
provided here
here and we just forced the pdf viewer
to validate
this signed content twice
and still our body updates were
implemented
were processed and for example foxhit or
masterpdf
were vulnerable against this kind this
type of attack
so the violation of our attacks we
consider it in uh
as part of our evaluation um 22
different viewers
among others adobe with different
versions
foxhead and so on and as you can see
11 of 22 were
vulnerable against incremental saving so
50
and we were quite surprised because we
saw that the developers so that
incremental updates
could be dangerous regarding the
signature validation
but we were still able to bypass
um their considerations
we had a full signature bypass
means that there is no possibility for
the victim to detect
the attack a limited signature bypass
means
that the victim if the victim clicks
on one at least one additional window
and explicitly wants to
validate the signature then
the viewer was vulnerable
but the most important thing is by
opening the file
there was a status message that the
signature validation
and all signatures are valid so this was
the first layer
and the viewers were vulnerable against
this so let's talk about
the second attack class we called it
signature wrapping attack and this is
the
most complex attack of the all three
classes
and now we have to go a little bit into
the details
how pdf signatures are made
so imagine now we have a pdf file
we have some header and the original
document
the original document contains the
header the body the
extra section and so on and so forth and
we want to sign
this document technically
again an incremental update is provided
and
we have a new catalog here we have
some other objects for example um
certificates and so on
and the signature objects and we will
now concentrate on this signature object
because it's essential for the attack we
want to
to carry out and the signature object
contains
a lot of information but we want for
this attacks only two elements are
relevant
the contents and the byte range
the contents contains the signature
value it's a pica cs7 container
containing the signature value and the
certificates used
to validate the signature
and the byte range the byte range
contains four different values
and what how these values are being used
the first two a and b
define define the first signed area
and this is here from the beginning of
the document
until the start of the signature value
why we need this because the signature
value is part of the side area so we
need to exclude the signature value from
the document computation
and this is how the byte range is used
the first part is and from the beginning
of the document
until the signed the signature value
starts
and after the signature ends until the
end of the file
um is the second area specified by the
two digits c and d
so now we have everything protected
besides the signature value itself
what we wanted to try is
to create additional space for our
attacks
so our idea was to move
the second signed area
and how can we do it so basically we can
do it
by just defining another byte range
and as you can see here the byte range
points
from area a to b so
this area we didn't made any
manipulation
in this part right it was not modified
at all so it's still valid
and the second part the new c value
and the next d bytes we didn't change
anything here
right so basically we didn't change
anything in the signed area
and the signature is still valid but
what we created
was a space for some malicious objects
um sometimes we needed some padding and
a new x-ray section
pointing to these malicious objects
important thing was that this malicious
x-ray
sections the position is defined by the
trailer
and since we cannot modify this trailer
this position is fixed so this is the
only limitation of the attack
but it works like a charm
and the question is now
how many uh pdf viewers were volume
against this attack
and as you can see this is
the signature wrapping column
17 out of 22 applications was
were vulnerable against this attack this
was a
quite expected result because
the attack was complex we saw that many
developers
didn't were not aware of this threat
and um that's the reason
why so many vulnerabilities were there
now to the last class of attacks
universal signature forgery
and we called it universal signature
forgery but
i prefer to use another
definition for this attacks i call them
stupid implementation flaws
um we are coming from the pen testing
area
and i know a lot of you are pen testers
too
and many of you have
experienced quite interesting experience
with zero bytes null values
or some kind of weird values
and this is what we tried
in this kind of attacks just try to do
some
stupid values or remove
references and see what happen
considering the signature there are two
different
um important elements the contents
containing the signature value and the
byte range pointing to
what is exactly signed so
what would happen if we removed the
contents
our hope was that the information
regarding the signature
is still shown by the viewer
as valid without validating any
signature because it was not possible
and by just removing the signature value
is quite
obvious idea and we were not successful
with this kind of attack but let's
proceed with another values like for
example contents without any value
or contents like equals null
or zero bytes and considering this last
version we had two viewers
which were vulnerable against this
attack
and um
another um another case is uh for
example by removing the byte range
by removing this byte range we have some
signature value but we
we don't know what is exactly signed
so um we tried this attack
and of course byte range without any
value
or null bytes or byte range
with a minus or negative
negative numbers and usually this last
crashed very a lot of years
but the most interesting is that adobe
made this mistake by just removing the
byte range
we were able to bypass the entire
security
we didn't expect this behavior but it
was a stupid
implementation flaw allowing us to do
anything in this document
and all the exploits we show in our
presentations were made on adobe with
this
attack so let's see
what were the results of this attack as
you can see
only four of 22 viewers were vulnerable
against this attack
and only adobe unlimited for the others
there was limitation because if you
click on the signature validation
um then warning was thrown
it was very easy for adobe to fix and as
you can see adobe didn't mistake
um made any mistake regarding
incremental saving and signature
wrapping but regarding universal
signature forgery
they were vulnerable against this attack
and this was
the hope of our approach in summary
we were able to break 21 of
22 pdf viewers the only
thanks
the only secure pdf viewer is
adobe 9 which is
um deprecated and has remote code
execution the only
the only users allowed to use them or
are using it are linux users because
this is the last
version available for linux and that's
the reason why you consider it
so i'm done with the talk about pdf
signatures
and now fabian can talk about pdf
encryption thank you
yes
okay now that we've dealt with
signatures let's talk about another
cryptographic aspect in pdfs
and that is encryption and some of you
might remember
our pdf x vulnerability from earlier
this year
it's of course an attack with a logo
and it presents two novel tech
techniques targeting pdf encryption that
have never been applied to pf encryption
before
so one of them is the so-called direct
acceleration
where we break the cryptography without
even touching the cryptography
so knife has no ciphertex manipulation
here
the second one are so called
malleability gadgets
and those are actually targeted
modifications
of the ciphertext of the document but
first
let's take a step back and let again
take some keywords in so pdf uses
is okay well is
is good nothing can go wrong right so
let's go home
encryption is fine well of course we
didn't stop here
but take a closer look so
they use cbc mode of operation so cipher
block chaining
and what's more important is that they
don't use
any integrity protection so it's
unintegrity protected iscbc
and you might remember this scenario
from the attacks against encrypted
emails so against
openpgp and s mime it's basically
the same problem but first
who actually uses pdf encryption you
might ask
for one we found some local banks in
germany use
encrypted pdfs as a drop-in replacement
for s9 or open pgp
because their customers might not want
to deal with
um set with the setup of encrypted email
second one where some drop-in plugins
for encrypted email as well
so there are some companies out there
that produce a product that you can put
into your outlook and you can use
encrypted pdf files instead of encrypted
email
we also found that some scanners and
medical devices were able to send
encrypted pdf files via email so you can
set
a password on that machine and they will
send the encrypted pdf via email
and you have to put in the password some
other way
and lastly we found that some
governmental organizations use
encrypted pdf documents for example the
us department of justice
allows for the sending in some claims
via encrypted pdfs
and i've exactly no idea how you how
they get the password but
at least they're allowed so as we are
from academia
let's take a step back and look at our
attacker model
so we've got alice and bob alice wants
to send document
to bob and she wants to send it over an
unencrypted channel
or a channel she doesn't trust so of
course she decides to encrypt it
second scenario is they want to upload
it to
a shared storage for example dropbox or
any other shared storage
and of course they don't trust the
storage so again they use
end-to-end encryption so let's assume
that
this shared storage is indeed
dangerous or malicious so alice
will of course again upload the
encrypted document to the attacker in
this case
we'll perform some targeted modification
of that
and will send the modified document back
to bob
who will happily put in the password
because from his point of view
it's undistinguishable from the original
document and
the original plain text will be leaked
back to the attacker
breaking the confidentiality so let's
take a look at the first attack
on how we did that that's the direct
acceleration so breaking the
cryptography
without touching any cryptography as i
like to say
but first encryption in up in a nutshell
pdf encryption so you have seen the
structure of a pdf document there's a
header with a version number
there's a body where all the interesting
objects live so there's our confidential
content
that we want to actually
to actually exfiltrate as an attacker
and finally
there's xrf table and the trailer
so what changes if we decide to encrypt
this document
well actually not a whole lot so instead
of the confidential data of course
there's now some encrypted ciphertext
okay
and the rest pretty much remains the
same the only thing that is added
is a new value in the trailer that tells
us
how to decrypt this data again
so there's pretty much of the structure
left
unencrypted and we thought about
why is this and we took a look at the
standard
so this is an excerpt from the pdf
specification
and i've highlighted the interesting
parts for you encryption is only applied
to strings and streams well those are
the
values that actually can contain any
text in a document
and all other objects are not encrypted
and that is because
well they want to allow random access to
the whole document
so no passing the whole document before
actually
showing page 16 of the encrypted
document
well that seems kind of reasonable
so but that also means that the whole
document structure is unencrypted
and only the streams and strings are
encrypted this reveals a lot of
information to an attacker that
he or she shouldn't have probably that's
for one the number and size of pages
that's the number and size of objects in
the document
and that's also including any links
so any hyperlinks in document that are
actually there
so that's a lot of information an
attacker probably shouldn't have
so next we thought maybe we can do
some more stuff can we add our own
unencrypted content
and we took a look at the standard again
and found that there are so called crypt
filters which provide
finer granularity control of the
encryption this basically means as an
attacker i can
change a document to say hey only
strings
in this document are encrypted and
streams are unencrypted that's what the
identity filter is for
i have no idea why they decided to add
that to a document format but it's there
so that means there's support for
partial encryption and that means
attacker's content can be mixed with
actual encrypted content
and we found 18 different techniques to
do that in different readers
so there's a lot of ways to do that in
the different readers
so let's have a look at the demo
so we have this document this encrypted
document we put in our password
and get our secret message we now
open it again in a text editor we see
in object 40 down here there's the
actual cipher text of the object
so the message and we see it's is
encrypted with a 32-byte key so
it's is 256. okay
now we decide to add a new object that
contains
well plain text and well
we simply add that to the contents array
of this document so
we say display this on the first page
save the document
reopen it and we'll put in our password
and oh well this is indeed awkward
okay so now we have broken
the integrity of an encrypted document
well
you might think maybe they didn't want
any integrity in their encrypted files
maybe that's the use case people have i
don't know
but we thought maybe we can somehow
exfiltrate the plain text this way
so again we took a step back and looked
at the pdf specification
and the first thing we found were so
called
submit form actions and that's basically
in the same as form on a website you can
put in data you might have seen this in
a contract in a pdf contract where you
can put in your name
and your address and so on and so on
and the data that is saved inside of
that
is saved in strings and streams
and now remember that is everything that
is encrypted in a document
and of course you can also send that
back to an attacker
or well to a legitimate use case of
course
while clicking a button but clicking
buttons is pretty lame
so we again looked at the standard and
found the so called open action
and that is an action for example
submitting a form
that can be performed upon opening a
document
so how might this look this is how a
pdf form looks already with the attack
applied
so we've got an url here
that is unencrypted because all strings
in this document are unencrypted
and we've got the value object2o
where the actual encrypted data lives
so that is the value of the form field
and what will happen on the attacker
side as soon as this document is opened
well we'll get a post request with the
confidential content
let's have a demo again we have this
document
we put in our password it's the original
document you have already seen we reopen
it in a text viewer
or a text editor again see it's
encrypted
and we decide to change
all strings to the identity filter so no
encryption is applied to strings from
now on and then
we add a whole blob of information for
the open action and for the form so this
will be open
this will be performed as soon as the
document is opened there's a ul
p df and the value is the encrypted
object
40. we start an http server
on the domain we specified we open the
document
put in the password again and as soon as
we open the document
adobe will helpfully show us a warning
but they will already
click the button for remembering that
for the future and if you accept that
you will see your secret message on the
attacker server
and that is pretty bad already
okay the same works for hyperlinks so
of course there are links in pdf
documents and as on the web we can
define a base url for hyperlinks
so we can save all urls
from this document start with http p.e f
and of course we can define any object
as a url
so any object we prepare this way
can be sent as a url and that will of
course trigger get request upon opening
the document again
if we defined an open action for the
same object
so again pretty bad and breaks the
confidentiality
and of course everybody loves javascript
and pdf files
and that works as well
okay let's talk about ciphertext attacks
so actual cryptographic attacks
no more not touching the crypto so you
might remember the e-fail attacks
on openbgp and s mime
and those had basically three
prerequisites
one were ciphertext many abilities so
it's called mediability gadgets
that's why we need ciphertex variability
and we've got no integrity protection
that's
a plus then we need some known plain
text
for actual targeted modifications and we
need an exfiltration channel to send the
data back to an attacker
well acceleration channels are already
dealt with as we have
hyperlinks and forms so we can already
check that
nice let's talk about ciphertext
mediability or
or what we call gadgets so
some of you might remember this from
crypto101 or
whatever lecture you ever had on
cryptography this is the decryption
function of
cbc so cypher blockchaining and
it's basically you've got your
ciphertext
up here and your
plain text down here and it works by
simply decrypting a block of ciphertext
xoring the previous block of
text onto that and you'll get the plain
text so what happens
if you decide to change a single bit in
the cipher text
for example the first bit of the
initialization vector
well that same bit will flip in the
actual plain text
wait a second what happens if we happen
to know a whole plain text block
well we can ixor that onto the first
block
and basically get all zeros or what we
call
a gadget or a blank sheet of paper
because
we can write on that by taking a chosen
plain text
and ignoring that onto this result
and this way we can for example
construct urls in the actual ciphertext
or in the actual
resulting plain text what we can also do
with this gadget
is gadgets is moving them somewhere else
in the document
cloning them so we can have multiple
gadgets at multiple places in the cipher
text
but remember if you do that there's
always
other launch effect of cbc's so you will
have some random bytes in here
but the url still remains in place
okay that's ciphertext mediability done
as i've said we need some plain text we
need to have some known plaintext and
as the pdf standard has been pretty
helpful up until now in breaking pdf
encryption
let's take a look again and with what we
found where
permissions so pdf document can have
different permissions
for the author and the user of the
document
this basically means the author can edit
the document and the users might not be
able to do that
and of course people started to change
with that well it
started to tamper with that value if it
was left unencrypted
so in the newest version it was decided
this should be encrypted
as a 16 byte value so we've got 16 bytes
how do they look well at first we need
room for extension we need
lots of permissions then we put four
bytes
of the actual permission value that is
also an unencrypted formula document
then we need one byte for encrypted
metadata
and for some reason we need some acronym
adb
i'll leave it to you to figure out what
that stands for
and finally we've got four random bytes
because we have to fill up 16 bytes and
we have run of out of ideas
okay we take all of that encrypt it
and oh well we know a lot of that and
that is basically known plain text by
design
which is bad let's look at how this
looks in a document
so you see the perms value i've marked
it down here that is the actual extended
value i've shown you
on the last slide and above that you see
the
unencrypted value that's inside this
pumps value so the minus four in this
case it's basically a bit field
on the right side you see the actual
encrypted contents
and helpfully all of this is encrypted
under the same document white key in the
newest version of the specification
and that means we can reuse this plain
text
anywhere in the document we want and we
can reuse this to build gadgets
to send that last point up for you adobe
decided to add permissions to the pdf
format
and people started tampering with them
so they decided to encrypt these
permissions to prevent tampering
and now known plain text is available to
attackers
all right so
that's basically all of the
prerequisites done and let's again
have a have a demo
so we again open this document put in
our password
well as soon as chrome decides to open
this document
we put in our password it's the same
as before now i've prepared a script for
you because
i really can't do this live and it
basically does what i've told you
it's getting a blank gadget from the
pumps value it's generating a url from
that
it's generating a field name so that it
will look nice on the server side
we regenerate this document and put a
form in there
we start a web server open this modified
document
put in the password again and oh well
chrome doesn't even ask
so as soon as this document is opened in
chrome and the password is put in
we'll get our secret message delivered
to the attacker
okay
so we took a look at 27 viewers
and found all of them vulnerable to at
least one of our attacks
so some of them work with no user
interaction as you have seen in chrome
some work with user interaction in
specific cases as you've seen with adobe
with a warning
but generally all viewers were
attackable
in one way or the other so what can be
done about all of this
well you might think signatures might
help that's
usually the first point people bring up
a signature on the encrypted file will
help
well no not really why is that
well for one a broken signature does not
prevent opening the document
so it will still be exfiltrated as soon
as the password is put in
signatures can be stripped because they
are not encrypted and as you have seen
before they can also be forged in most
viewers
signatures are not the answer closing
filtration channels
is also not the answers because the
answer because for one it's hard to do
and how would you even find all
excitation channels in eight patented
pages standard
and i mean we have barely scratched the
surface here of excitation channels and
should we really move
forms and hyperlinks from documents and
should we move javascript okay maybe we
should
and finally if you have to do that
please ask the user before connecting to
a web server
so let's look at some vendor reactions
apple decided to do exactly what i've
told you to add a dialog
to warn the user and even show the whole
url with the encrypted plain text
and google decided to stop trying to fix
the unfixable in chrome
they fixed the automatic exfiltration
but there's really nothing they can do
about the standard so this is a problem
that has to be done in the standard
and that is basically that for
mitigating wrapping attacks we have to
deprecate partial encryption
and disallow access from unencrypted to
encrypted objects
and against the gadget attacks we have
to use authenticated encryption like
is gcm
okay and adobe has told us that they
will be escalating this to the iso
working group that's now responsible for
the pdf standard
and this will be taken up in the next
revision
so that's a win in my book
thank you so much guys that was really
awesome uh please queue up by the
microphones if you have any questions we
still have some time left for q a
um but i think your research is really
really interesting because it opens my
mind to like
how would this actually be able to be
misused in practice
like and and i don't know like what's
your take i guess since you've been
working so much with this you must have
some kind of
idea as to what devious things you could
come up with
i mean it's still an attacker scenario
that requires a lot of resources and
a very motivated attacker so this might
not be very important to the
normal user let's be real here so most
of us are not targeted by the nsa
i guess so you need an active attacker
an active man in the middle to actually
perform these attacks
great thank you and then i think we have
a question from microphone number four
please uh yes you said that the next
standard might have a fix
do you know a time frame on how long it
takes to
build such a standard
well no we don't really know we have
talked with adobe and
they told us they will show the next
version of the standard to us before
actually releasing that
but we have no time frame at all for
them okay thank you
thank you microphone number five please
thank you for the very interesting talk
um you showed in the first part
that the signature has like these four
numbers with the byte range
and why is this
like four numbers not part of the
signature
is there a technical reason for that
because the byte offset is predictable
it is the byte range is protected by the
signature but
we just defined the second one and just
moved the signed one to be validated
later
so there are two byte ranges okay but
only but only the first one
the manipulated one will be processed
thank you thank you so much microphone
number four please
um oh this is way too high for me
okay i have an answer and a question for
you
uh you mentioned during the talk that
you weren't sure how the department of
justice distributes the
passwords for encrypting pdfs
the answer is in plain text in a
separate email
or as the password of the week
which is distributed through various
means
that is also what the department of
homeland security does
and the military is somewhat less stupid
um
as a question i have roughly a half
terabyte
of sensitive pdfs that i would like to
scan
for your attack and also
for redaction failures
do you know of any fast feasible ways to
scan
documents for uh the presence of this
kind of attack
i don't know of any tools but i mean
scanning for
the gadget attacks is actually possible
if you try to
do some entropy detection so because you
reuse ciphertext you will have less
entropy in your ciphertext
but that's pretty hard to do diode
acceleration should
probably be detectable by scanning
simply for words like
identity or the other 18 different
techniques that we
provided in the paper but i don't know
of any tools to do that
automatically thank you
great thank you and microphone number
two please
thank you for very interesting
presentation i have one suggestion and
one question
for the mitigation scheme if you simply
run your
pdf reader in a virtual machine that's
firewalled away so your firewall will
let you to anybody
going out but for the signature
forgeries i had an idea i'm not sure if
this is
actually a stupid idea but did you
consider faking the certificate
because presumably the signature is
protected by the
certificate you make up your own sign it
with that does it catch it and how
we consider it but not in this paper
um we assumed that the certificates and
the entire chain of trust
for this part is totally secure
it was just an assumption to just
concentrate only on attacks we
we already found so perhaps there
there will be further research
provided by us in the next months and
years
we might just hear more from you in the
future thank you so much
and now questions from the internet
please
um uh i have two questions to the first
part of your talk
um from the internet the first one is
uh you mentioned a few reactions but can
you give
a bit more detail about your experience
with vendors while reporting these
issues
yeah we for the first time we started
um we we asked
the third team from bsi setbund
um to help us because there were a lot
of
affected vendors and we were not able to
to to provide the support in them
in a feasible way so they supported us
the entire way
we first created a report with
containing the exact description of the
vulnerabilities
and all the exploits then we distributed
it to the bsi
and they contacted the vendors
and just proxied the communication and
there was
a lot of communication so i'm not aware
of the entire communication
but only about the technical stuff where
we were asked to just um
retest the the fix and so on so there
was a reaction
um from adobe fox it and a lot of
viewers reacted on our attacks and
contacted us
but not everybody thank you so much
unfortunately that's the
only time that we have available for
questions today i think you guys might
stay around for
a couple of minutes just if someone has
any more questions
fabian icing and vladislav thank you so
much
it was very interesting please give them
a great round of applause
thank you
you